why airplane windows round this seems
like a simple question but let's take a
look as passenger planes became more
popular planes needed to fly higher
flying higher means less drag because
the air density is lower in the upper
atmosphere so less fuel is wasted
flying high also means a more
comfortable flight because the plane can
now fly above the turbulent lower
atmosphere but some design changes need
to be made to allow this first the cabin
has to be pressurized to create a
survivable environment for the
passengers second the cabin must be
cylindrical in shape because a cylinder
can resist the new internal pressure but
one design flaw was not corrected when
cabin pressurization was first
introduced the windows remained square
so why is this a problem as a plane
increases in altitude the external
atmospheric pressure lowers more than
the internal cabin pressure this creates
a pressure difference between the inside
and outside of the plane causing the
plane to expand ever so slightly when a
material change is shaped like this
stress is created in the material as the
material is stretched more and more if
the stress begins to rise eventually the
stress can rise so high that the
material breaks and there are a lot of
factors that can elevate this stress one
of them is the shape of the material in
planes the shape of the windows has huge
effect on the level of stress stress
will flow smoothly through material but
if an obstacle is placed in its path
like a window it needs to change
direction and this causes the pressure
to build in certain locations this is
called stress concentration comparing
modern-day oval windows and square
windows you can see that the square
windows provide a larger barrier to the
smooth flow of stress and this means
that the stress builds in the sharp
corners of the window this elevated
stress created by the square windows
actually caused cracks to form in the de
Havilland comet causing three tragic
crashes the investigations that followed
led to our a greater understanding of
stress concentration and that is why all
plane windows are now oval in shape